Mà khoang en 2,5 năm, hình khu trong 2 mấy sấu, trên khu vực hủ thức bà, xa bảo ảy, tình lòng cài, xe ra vụ lịch tổ chở hết khiến sống với mất tích.
Ngai trong đêm, nhận được lệnh của cấp trên về việc cơ động lực lượng đi tình kiếm nạn nhân mất tích vụ lịch tổ.
Lứ đoàn đặc công hải quân một 2 xấu đã hình chương làm công tác chình bị điều động lực lượng.
Phong tệ đi tình kiếm kếu nạn, lứ đoàn đã đều động 2 mì đồng chỉ đã công nghệ nhái có kinh nghiệm của mấy lạng sầu.
Sù cứ là, may nền khi và nhiều loại chân tích bị cứu nạn khác, từ hải phòng cơ động đến hộ thấp bà để tổ chức tình kiếm các nạn nhân mất tích.
Đến bà giờ 3 mì phút hôm nay, lực lượng cứu nạn của lưỡi đoàn đã có mặt tại hình chương và cơ động ra vị trí tình kiếm.
Tự tá phạm ngọt tân anh, phó lưỡi đoàn trường lưỡi đoàn một 2 xấu, chức tiếp chỉ vì lực lượng tình kiếm của đơn vị cho biết, hiện tại khu vực hộ thức bà xe mù dài đặc, mưa nhau.
Hồ có độ sâu lưỡi đoàn nhất khoảng 18 mết, đến sau giờ 4.5 cung ngày, các tổ nguyễn nhái của lưỡi đoàn đã tính hành lạnh kìm tra trong tương tầu bị lịch và tình kiếm các nạn nhân ở các khu vực xung quanh.
Đến bà giờ 4.5 cung ngày, lượng lượng người nhái của lưỡi đoàn đã vất được thi thế một nạn nhân lại chóo hằng nước mạnh, sinh năm 2019, ở thu muột xác càng nhân tình là kai.
Khiến các tổ đoàn của lưỡi đoàn tích tục quen cùng về tình kiếm các nạn nhân còn lại.